now it's time to meet one of the
season's top scorers 25 year old car in
Bella Robbie this season that German
Moroccan winger was Labor coussins top
forward with 12 goals and nine assists
he also got called up to the German
national team and did well the
fleet-footed Bella Robbie dribbled his
way to success and added one more
feather to his cap the fastest goal in
bundesliga history that's it you scored
the fastest bundesliga goal in history
nine seconds into the first round of the
season did you find yourself thinking
this is gonna be my year come to get on
kickoff hate us with man y'all had to
melt these elderly for a year I really
am to hit the gas and gave it my best
shot I worked out a lot even ahead of
training camp and I was pleased about my
preparation yeah some eternity get Floyd
and master when I've scored at first I
didn't know it was at nine seconds when
I found out afterwards I was really
happy and I hope that record stands for
a while she's dagger Floyd I'm jovid I
said he caught numbers on it
then come then you got a call from the
coach of the German national team you
all came lurve where were you at the
time um I vice got salsa I was home with
my family my mom dad and sister 21 got
on it all happened to be there on that
day when I got the call and of course I
was happy because I the coach told me he
was satisfied with my Bundesliga
performance and I deserve to be called
up naturally it was a big surprise
because I really didn't expect it to
come so quickly he's socially I bother
me and my family were over the moon you
mind if I meet on Tuesday at swellburger
for your entire career kicked off on
Carl ertz's casa in Bremen this weekend
in dec pal whoops I straße in Bremen the
Hansa you played football over there on
that fenced-in cinder pitch the cage
right zolina face what did it teach you
the avant the integrals gurgaon that's
Daniel nah I learned a bunch of things
that have stuck with me I'm i can't say
precisely what hobo that's tambien I
can't say that we went out to play every
day and learned all our skills Leon
Topham on a [ __ ] sawhorse maybe I owe
my speed to those days Oscar god I can't
say for sure vice noodles the edge of
the mission I only know that the older
kids picked me early on when we were
dividing up teams and that of course
gave me self-confidence um sup minute to
stenoses pavelski Kim that's what Mark
did Holger Schmidt plane your success
how their goal isn't a big one I
couldn't have done it this year without
the coach he gave me confidence from the
get-go and said I could do better and
supportive me and what I was already
good at want uh yeah that's important
for a player to have a good trusting
relationship with the coach time your
stand on FEMA me Gisborne Roger
understand this is all 50 HP de I think
all young players need the trust and
confidence of their coach and Club
speedo and I've always had that here in
leverkusen I find him till you know if
I'm fine the club's always been behind
me so we've extended my contract this
year
that's positive and it fit with the rest
of the year for divers into GDC all on
the positivity sister from my aunt yeah
how do you say I nice capacity varium
munch off that's it which Bundesliga
team took you by surprise in 2014-15
Talia ballast um none of them was a
total surprise I nisha [ __ ] another way
munich our way out ahead but they do
what they do very well on a tradition
Salzburg where maybe a slight surprise
but before the season even started you
could see they had lots of quality
quality and i think they also played
really well the leading teams were no
surprise let me go and the bottom of the
table the sustad was yeah um kidding us
hello I know all about that I know I was
on loan to braunschweig for a year and
they were fighting relegation every
weekend according all open even on the
last day of play it was still about who
was going down so that was tense I was
legit my thought is still a shame when
great teams clubs with tradition and
lots of fans end up relegated but this
year it might happen to a big team and
then we'll see what happens i'm sami
michael state's i'm behind this year